[Music]
fetty wap's four-year-old daughter
lauren maxwell
reportedly died of heart defect
complications
now the toddler's mother lisa pembroke
also known as turquoise miami
is shutting down those reports insisting
that the autopsy quote
isn't done yet according to tmz the
toddler's death certificate cites that
she died from a fatal cardiac arrhythmia
due to complications from congenital
cardiac anomalies
which means she had this heart problem
since she was born
and the resulting irregular heartbeat
ultimately killed her
also according to tmz lauren died on
june 24th at her home in riverdale
georgia
but on thursday shortly after tmz
claimed to have obtained the
four-year-old's death certificate
turquoise miami took to instagram to
slam the reports
quote this is what y'all people do for
fun all y'all
her death certificate says cardiac
arrhythmia due to congenital
heart defect but that is not the full
cause of her death
that is why the autopsy hasn't come back
she went on writing in part
how dare y'all go steal my child's death
certificate
and announce the cause of death before
anybody was ready
adding y'all love breaking news so bad
but this
is my life both fetty and turquoise have
posted
touching tributes to their daughter the
trap queen rapper took to instagram on
tuesday
sharing this sweet snap of his little
girl dressed in a rainbow shirt
smiling big for the camera the caption
hey mini me my twin i love you to the
moon and back forever and
ever best friend the 30 year old also
got emotional during an instagram live
on monday where he asked fans to do him
a favor by posting all butterfly emojis
thank god i appreciate y'all fetty wiped
away tears as he explained that the
request was in honor of his daughter who
quote
loved butterflies
as for the toddler's mom she revealed
the tragic news in a heartbreaking post
to instagram over the weekend
posting this sweet clip of lauren
playing around in a swimming pool
alongside the caption quote this is my
amazing beautiful funny vibrant
loving talented smart and hard-headed
princess mermaid aquarius
if you see this post scrolling by with
her comment or just say to yourself
i love you lauren because they say that
souls can feel your love
and last month while performing at the
rolling loud music festival in miami
fetty dedicated his set to his baby girl
at the time he took to his insta story
writing quote
lolo daddy did that for you last night
baby girl
you